Alright.
Latif if you can rewind your mind back to a time when your life wasn't dominated
by Alan Fund and Candy Camera. Like how did, how does it start? So I first, I,
I di unlike a lot of people, I did not grow up watching candid camera.
I had never heard of candid camera when I was younger. Never. Or candid camera.
No. Well,
how have you heard of the declaration of independence that ring the bell?
Did Allen Funt right there? No, but it's sort of, he's up there with it.
It's very noticeable. Okay. Okay, cool.
He is actually a no, no BS,
a founding father in a way of, of a different story. Hey,
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab when you least expect it.
Your executive order, the one today. Just to set that up.
So there used to be a time in our media history where like the line between show
and life was really clear.
Then along came a guy named Allen Funt who muddied that line in a way that was
fascinating and would bite him in the butt. In fact, uh, spiritually speaking,
I think those bite marks are on all of our butts.
So check your Tush and listen to the story from our producer Latif Nasser.
So I first heard about cannon camera a few years ago and I, when I did,
I just dove in deep. Like I just binged all of,
I watched every single clip I could get my hands on.
And then that's around the time when I found out that it started as a radio
show, which was even more interesting to me cause I was like a radio show.
I was like w like how does that even make sense? Like what does that even,
what would that be?
So I called up one of the few people who have studied this.
That's right. Um, so I'm Jacob Smith,
an associate professor at Northwestern University School of communication and
the director of Northwestern's masters in sound arts and industries.
And it turns out there's this kind of wonderful, kind of creepy backstory.
Do you just want to start with World War Two? Yeah.
So during World War Two,
Alan Funt was working in the signal corps is known as the nerves of the, uh,
the kind of communications arm for the armed forces at that time. So fun.
He's a, a few years out of college by this point.
He is stationed in Oklahoma at Camp Gruber.
And his job there is to make radio shows for the armed forces radio.
One of these shows, it's called the great booth. The Gripe GRI p.
E the gripe booth. Yeah. Basically the show worked like this.
Fun would get told your station at the camp to come into his studio and talk
about their gripes, about like their barracks and about the food and about,
you know, their girlfriend is cheating on them back home or whatever, you know,
things that were bothering them. Thinks it's a very good idea for morale. Oh,
I think it's a great idea from her. I really,
I would imagine it would bring the soldiers down. It would bring them down,
but maybe it would bring them together. Fair enough. Anyhow,
so he's bringing these soldiers into his little recording studio and one of the
things that he found was that as soon as the red light would go on to indicate
that recording was going on, they'd clam up.
They would get tongue tied. This idea was actually called Mike Fright, Mike,
Right? Mike Fry.
And he tells these stories about how it was amazing to see these soldiers who
would go out into battle without maybe blinking an eye but break into a cold
sweat at the thought of sitting in front of a microphone. So what was,
what's he do? What does he do? Well,
so his solution was to disconnect the red light and record them secretly.
So basically he'd bring them in and say, okay, let's just do a practice around,
let's just talk over the things that,
the kinds of things you will talk about just for practice. And then when,
then finally they were ready to start, he'd be like, no, no, I already got it.
He would get better material when they didn't know they were being recorded.
Would they be okay with that? Like you said,
well you would get like a mission afterwards. So is that a lie? No,
I don't think it's lie anymore. It's a sort of truth deferred, you might say
[inaudible] but according to Jacob Smith Fund was like, this is a great trick.
Yes. You know, the red light goes off in the great booth,
but a red light goes on in funds mind. And so after the war,
he pitches this idea as candid microphone.
What kind of microphone,
which goes on the air on ABC in 1947
no program that brings you the secretly recorded conversation live.
All kinds of people as they react in real life.
Do all kinds of situations. No one ever knows when he's talking.
[inaudible] me, me, me, me, me, me.
Mm. No.
Alright,
so this is Sonny Fox and he was one of the original guys to work with Alan on
candidate microphone. And it just so happened when he came into our studio,
we managed to catch him on our candid microphone. Can you hear me?
I can. That is tepid water. Tepid water. I'm, I'm sorry the water's not, uh,
you know, not to my life up to snuff and my standards.
Why is my throat so tidy? That's the tepid water.
Now all of a sudden that's not so a bourbon would've helped.
All right. Okay. We're here to talk about much more exciting things I think.
So when you were working with Alan on candidate microphone, what was he like?
Like how did you see him like, yeah, that was a very able,
very bright young guy at, he had a face of an every man.
These big chipmunk cheeks rather short and a little plump probably was about
five, 10. And uh,
he could charm you when he wanted to show me right out of your shoes or he could
be wildly maniacal,
overwrought person. I mean, he had this huge temp,
Tony says when they were just starting to show sometimes Alan would get so mad,
he would throw things sometimes like throwing pencils at other producers. Well,
there were only four of us and the secretary, that was it.
That was the core of what we did. And we all had to do everything. I mean, Alan,
the hidden microphone,
that man was Allen Allen was the auditor obviously of whether we did something
didn't just happen. You feel what was like, what was the goal for the show?
The goal was to,
I was to reflect people as they are in their unguarded Amish.
We try to bring you the real Macaulay on candid microphone.
That's what fascinated fun. The beauty of everyday conversation.
We go out of the studio into the world everyday life kept your rock handed
glimpses of people like you.
What the sociologist Erving Goffman calls bugging the backstage, right?
So what we would do is every day Sonny and crew would go to their office in
Manhattan's room office, sit down at their desks and think up ideas separately,
scratching our heads and say the Allan, what about
I have, I gave every day if I'm gay, my wife gets right after me.
Like, what if we bugged a barbershop or a magazine stand? Oh,
maybe that's something we could, you know?
Yeah, things are green or green,
a restaurant or shoe store. I don't know where.
So what they do is they take this big clunky portable recorder.
It was like a suitcase. It weighed, I think maybe 60 pounds,
but they put a handle on top and said it's supportable.
He says that they would lug around this massive suitcase to wherever it was they
were recording and they try to hide it so that no one would see it.
So they could record this tape, which they did
in all these different locations, including the women's bathroom.
I don't know. I could say I really don't.
But by and large, uh,
the tape they gathered front was disappointed to discover that it was the most
uninteresting garbage you could imagine. Yeah. It was frustrating.
It doesn't have, you know, the nice shape, the rise and fall,
the climax that, um, is gonna keep listeners hooked.
No,
that presented us with indeed problem. They had a half hour show,
prime time that they needed to fill. Here's how desperate I was.
I was having a date first date with a young woman. Yeah.
I bugged my car and try to see how she would sound on a first date.
She found out about that it was not amused. And that was the last day.
How did it go though? I was not very interesting.
You got to that point where anything was, you were so desperate to get stuff,
you did unlikely things like that.
So here they had this show that was supposed to be about real people,
real talk everyday conversation, but turned out that sucked.
So then the question became, how can we mix it up? How can we stir it up?
How can we, um, change this into something more spectacular?
And that's when Ellen Fun added a little wrinkle.
It's something that Jacob Smith has called. I was calling it the Rhio.
So the basic idea of the [inaudible] is that instead of just letting people
Yammer on, which didn't seem to work, you gotta get in there,
you've gotta juice the action to get that right shape.
My man with a hitting Mike had a good one when he dropped in the tailor shop.
What'd you start to hearing? Candid. Mike is like these strange situation.
Like he would go into a tailor shop with a microphone up his sleeve and would
ask the guy,
I have to have food and clothes made up for kangaroo kangaroo. That's right.
Oh, you can handle that.
Like here's another one. Play the moaning Trump. This is sunny, his favorite.
He says that, uh,
one day they called a mover to come over to their office to move this trunk
and inside the trunk.
The mover did know this was a guy and his job was to sound Erie to basically
moon. Every time they move or tried to move that trunk,
just be very gentle or where they were there.
What did you nevermind. Just just take it by the makeup. Nice. I wondered a lot.
Just forget it. I'm blessing now. We've been trying to get rid of those things.
[inaudible] delivered to 180 I give us mass slip. What do you mean a slip?
I want to have a sickness. You're not delivered there.
I want to have to take an aside for that. My goddess look for man.
Oh,
the Phil's got off such great mo classic format that works for Alan.
We're just getting people into situations where they were fresh.
No, it's not your business whatsoever, which makes up kind of noise.
There's no noise. You don't hear anything said to me and I don't hear anything.
Come on. Oh, we've been waiting since last night.
Let's get this thing out of here.
It just keeps going and going and going. Gives me the three.
Did the ambulance come on? Don't in mind what it is now.
Just driving them nuts. What's in a drunk until finally
[inaudible]
here's your $20 they look for another man.
They lose their temper and we get cue the music
[inaudible]
the climax. That's the closure. Now the whole thing has a shape.
It starts slow and then crescendo, crescendo, crescendo, boom.
He's inventing this new kind of new format of entertainment.
It sounds totally obvious,
but this is basically like reality TV in a nutshell.
Like this is one of the first times where you have that familiar hybrid of this
highly artificial and constructed situation.
But then inside of it of snippet of life,
we've all been there situations where we've been frustrated where we don't
understand what's going. Yeah.
Situations where we'd be welded to fun would start pushing this format,
tweaking it, changing it, trying out new permutations.
And sometimes it's very much like a fly on the wall. You know, these,
these kind of poignant segments of listening to,
Huh. Um, it's time to get up
a wife trying to wake up her husband. Yes.
Ah, delving the clock nine 15 minutes ago. Hi Evan. Right up.
Yeah. That one's kind of beautiful. Uh, the temporary Zermatt guilty.
So intimate is what's so incredible, right?
Got a lot to do today. You're supposed to be in early
and this one fund got the wife to be in on the gag.
Come on darling. You can keep it. That's all stolen. Huh?
What was your wrap on? I wrote this,
I'll bring up this three along with your please get up. Please go away.
Tom. I think if you take a shower, you feel good. I think if you go here,
I don't like you talking to me that way once and for all.
I insist that you get up out of the bed. All right, I'm up.
I'm awake. Let's say you move, it's very late. It's nine o'clock,
nine o'clock.
So you know, you get this beautiful backstage glimpse of everyday life,
but where do we stop?
And obviously it did prompts letters that you hit this and cap called.
Have you heard the one where I was just listening to it the other day where, um,
where listener writes in to complain about that one? Yeah. Yeah.
That was actually really cool. Yeah. But tell us, tell us, tell us about it.
Well, so
one lady took us at our word and wrote us a few well chosen ones that really
made our ears,
she's writing into complaint that this was, you know, crossing the line. Right?
So what Funt does is he goes up to her door to talk to her,
but he goes with a hidden mic.
I wear the American Broadcasting Company.
And I wonder if I could have just a couple of minutes of your time.
Is that all right? Yeah. Uh,
you wrote the letter the other day about one of our program called a candid
microphone and I got it from your letter that you don't like it very much. No,
I don't. Well why, what are some of the things you find objectionable about it?
Well, I don't like it because I think it's snooping. I don't know anything
out notes.
Is that right?
In your letter you said you said a Lillian instead of a little more strongly.
Is that you thought were a bunch of dirty sneaking fine. Well, um,
I suppose at the time, and I was listening to the program, I felt that way.
You get these people in their homes extemporaneously. I had that one program,
uh, about the, the, you went into the man bedroom. Oh,
you mean the one where I wear a white, uh, awakened the hardest wagon,
the husband and never depart fellow.
He didn't know who he was talking for thinking for the public.
If they sort of put him in a bad light, don't you think?
Well you might have something. Yeah,
but don't you think it's funny that the man make money awakened? Yeah.
That's funny.
But there are only for him though and his own bedroom and I'm sure he doesn't
enjoy having the whole world know about it.
You or do you think most people are [inaudible] from top countries in front of a
microphone? Not Anymore. I think most people take to,
and I could talk very nicely. Do you feel, you talked at about the same way.
If you know you knew you were talking about Michael Ball right now,
that'd be no different. What do I know different? Well now look,
let me show you. This is the microphone and what you've just said is,
is ready to go out from coast to coast. Does that make any difference?
Then I said, good, fine. Thanks. Good away
your mind I coming in here and talking to you this way.
Do you think we took unfair advantage of you? I think so. At the moment,
the conversation may not be worth the nickel,
but would you like to have it on the air?
Yes. Gosh, I would.
Because I want the whole world to know.
I have my opinion on this presence.
Oh my God, that's amazing. She just switched. Exactly. And, and,
and you can hear in her voice this, this weird tension, right?
I have this one advisor, her name is Sheila Porsche. She has this idea,
I'm bastardizing it. But to put it crudely,
like we all kind of have these two drives,
one drive for privacy.
We don't want people in our bedrooms listening to us.
That is the height of creepiness. And then on the other hand,
we have this drive for publicity. It's exciting to be the star,
and it's exciting to have people pay attention to you.
And these two drives to drive for privacy and the drive for publicity are sort
of competing in us. So coming up that tension,
well, it just takes off. Literally.
No, actually, literally have takes up. Yes. Yeah. And it gets super interesting.
Yeah. That's after the break. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
Stay with us.
[inaudible]
this is Joshua Rush calling from Los Angeles.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hey, this is jad. Radiolab is supported by rocket mortgage by quicken loans.
Chances are you're confident when it comes to your work, your hobbies,
and your life.
Rocket mortgage gives you that same level of confidence when it comes to buying
a home or refinancing your existing home loan. Rocket mortgage is simple,
allowing you to fully understand all the details and be confident that you're
getting the right mortgage for you. To get started,
go to rocket mortgage.com/radiolab equal housing lender licensed in all 50
states. NMLS consumer access.org number 30 30
in the moments before Charles Kinsey was shot by police in summer 2016 he
pleaded with the autistic man next to him to lie down, lie down.
Then the cell phone video cuts.
I'm Audrey Quinn after effect is a new podcast from w n y c studios.
We tell the story behind the shooting and what happened next.
Listen and subscribe to after effect wherever you get your podcasts.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab.
Let's get back to our story from a producer Latif Nasser about Alan Funt,
the man with a hidden microphone where we left off.
He had just made a radio show called candid Mike. Well, so is it,
did in fact people like this program? Was it a hit? Oh yeah. Yeah.
It moves pretty quickly to television.
Adam, good camera with Allan. Fun
in the spring of 1949 the show premiers on NBC.
Welcome to the candid camera program
in the show. It's the exact same premise, setup weird or frustrating situations.
Try and catch people's reactions. But when the show goes out on TV,
here's the man who, according to Jacob Smith, it just doesn't catch on.
A lot of viewers think that it's mean-spirited,
that the subjects are being somehow, um, mistreated.
There were critics who were very unnerved and upset by it.
There were people certainly, but what, what did the critics say? Oh Man,
I made a list here of,
of a whole bunch of the criticisms from the forties and fifties and there are
great. They're like, so like they're so sweeping. So, okay. So, um,
so there was this one guy in the New Yorker, this is in 1950, um, who said,
and I love this, I love this for my money.
Candid camera is sadistic, poisonous,
anti human and sneaky. Uh, there was another,
hold on, there was another kind of great string of adjectives.
Let me just find it. Um, there's so many of these here. Uh,
another guy for different guy from the New Yorker. He, he found, uh,
Allen Funt course nagging suspicious and misanthropic and to make matters worst
zestfully so,
wow. But I mean, I think that becomes kind of a PR problem that he has to fix.
And according to Jacob Smith, it was not a small problem. No.
When it first aired, and even all through the 50s,
the show it's on and off doesn't really get its audience.
It moves around different networks and all the while he's tweaking it and
changing it, adapting it. And in the early sixties,
he hits on some [inaudible] a second little tweak that would make them all the
different funds. Term was the reveal,
the reveal. Now he'd done it here and there,
but by 1962 he locks it in.
You start to see this thing happen over and over at the end of segments. It's,
it's so commonplace now that it seems crazy. Someone even had to invent it.
Classic reveal is like [inaudible] the killing. Uh,
the gag is in a diner and they're serving this guy a tiny little teacup and what
is it?
And he wanted a big coffee mug and they serve in this tiny little tea cup and
he's like, what, what's going on? So this guy gets pissed off and,
and previously front would have let that keep going. But now
as the guy is about to blow fund either walks out himself or he sent someone out
and they, they kinda grabbed the guy and they're like,
do the camera in the back.
They show him the hidden camera on camera.
And as he's looking at that hidden here and he's like, Huh,
the camera zooms in on his face and Jacob Smith says a bit.
Sometimes fun would even actually have to hold the people in place for that very
moment because one of their first reactions are to turn away or to cover their
face.
So he would sometimes have to physically restrain them and turning them towards
the camera so that they can capture that one fleeting moment.
And in that moment you see so much on their face. They're, they're angry,
they're embarrassed, they're ashamed, they're confused,
they don't know how to feel. And then right at that moment,
font says the magic words smile.
You're on candid camera. And it's all, everything's Abdullah,
all the sudden aide. Okay. Everything is it. Okay. And then the core is,
but what you least expected, you did, you're the star today.
Smile. You're on candid camera. Yeah.
Something, something hocus pocus. You're in focused. Yes. It's your lucky day.
That's interesting. So it went from being like who you are.
You've been creeping bio to like, Oh,
thank you Alan Fund and this works much better. I take, yeah,
it was hugely successful. Well,
it was one of the top ranked shows from basically all of the early 1960s
millions, if not tens of millions of people watched it. Uh,
and I think part of the reason why was that without that sort of meanness,
they'd bled out the meanness and people could now sort of freely see it as what
it really was,
which were these kind of little people's into human nature.
Like the first one I ever saw was the elevator sketch.
Do you know the elevator to walk me through? Oh, the elevator sketch.
It's just really simple. It's really simple and it's so beautiful.
The gentleman in the elevator now is a candid star.
The basic setup is guy walks into an elevator. There's a hidden camera.
He doesn't know it is a fellow with his hat on in the elevator.
He is like everybody else wearing his overcoat and a hat and he stands in the
middle of the elevator.
And then all of the other people in the elevator who we later learned our
confederate, uh, they, um,
take off their hat and one by one by one, one hand off, two hats off,
five hats off,
and you're watching them through the open elevator door and he's just sort of
standing there awkwardly. And then he'd just sort of
hesitantly is he just takes off his hat and then holds it in front of his,
you know, chest procedure.
Then all of the people around him, they put their hats back on.
Then the knees are sort of, is looking around and like it's almost,
it's happening at this, it's somewhere between conscious and subconscious level.
And then he sort of just puts his hat back on.
It's funny, it's really, really sky wasn't in order. It was not in on it.
You clearly just was trying to, to fit in, in this weird way.
It's interestingly though, like I never watched the TV show when I was young,
but it's weird. Like we, uh, when I was seven, we still,
we would say all the time like, smile, you're on candid camera.
Even though I'd never seen the show.
So it was like the idea of the show was like in a way,
way bigger than the actual show. Yeah, you kind of became a meme but,
but it was less about kind of investigating human behavior and more about vanity
in this weird way.
It was like this idea that you dis tiny sliver of your private life could be
excised and then broadcast to the world. Um,
and that idea,
that idea would get away from Alan Font and it would go all over the world and
then it would come right back and bite him in the butt in this really funny and
strange way. What, what happened? Well, okay.
It starts like this. Hi there.
Hi. How are you? Good. Come on in. We'll start this story with this woman. Oh,
we are now Marilyn Fun.
Uh, the x y for Valen Fund and we're on,
do you want me to start when we're on the plane? Okay.
February 3rd, 1969, New York airport.
That's Maryland funds daughter Allan Funds Daughter Juliet Fund. My Mom, my dad,
my baby brother and I are on a flight
straight fly to Miami and I'm about one and a half so I don't have any personal
recollection of it, but she does,
she knows this story because it's like a family Lord.
So we were in first class and we were on the flight.
Oh largely uneventful flight for one's replying on that for about the first 20
minutes. It'd be an hour. Who knows?
There are about a hundred miles or so off shore and you know,
they get their meals and go to the bathroom and all of a sudden
a man stood up in the back of the flight end. He took out a knife
and he put it to the throat of the one of the flight attendants and he walked
her all the way down the center island into the cock
passing every passenger on the flight.
I did hear noises, which were a little bit different in the back.
That's Fred Weaver, retired eastern airlines pilots,
one of the flight crew and next to him. Yes sir. Copilot, Lowell Miller.
They were expecting breakfast.
You know,
I hear the knock on the door and I just opened the door and I turned around to
see who it was.
There she is a flight attendant with the hijacker behind her with a knife up
against her throat. He was agitated saying a Cuba, Cuba.
He also was saying that his friend had a bomb in the back of the chair.
[inaudible]
I knew right then I said, oh, here we go.
The stewardess was walking around
talking with all the passengers,
asking them if anybody knew how to speak Spanish. That's Jim. Zack.
He was back in coach. He was 11 years old at the time.
I didn't think much of it until, uh,
until the announcement came on the loudspeaker.
Pilot gets on and says, Ladies and Gentlemen,
Ladies and Gentlemen, we have some gentlemen up here that want to go to Cuba.
So we're going to Ivana.
And then came the part of the story that I've been told was the waiting,
the frozen silent,
staring at each other waiting portion.
But then this one woman a few rows away,
began to recognize my father and she began to look and look back and forth to
other folks and point a little bit and there was a slow building of her
certainty.
And then all of a sudden she pulled it up and said,
wait a second, we are not being hijacked.
It's a candid camera stunt.
I'm quoting him. The plane went absolutely crazy.
Everyone started laughing. People begin cheering.
Oh well, look, goes here. He's pulling me out of this done
stamping their feet and attention dripped off of the, everyone's so relieved.
People were lined up with their air sickness bags to get autographs from my
father. Then they relaxed and through all of this,
my dad is begging.
No, I know it's not me. I'm not involved.
We are being hijacked.
And they said, come on out.
So Alan Funt is trying to persuade people. He's not getting any purchase.
He sees uh, a behind him.
He sees a priest, right?
He runs over to the priest and said, father,
will you please help me convince these people? Tell them, this is no joke.
This is not a stunt up maniac is for real and what is the guy say,
you can't get me Allan. Oh No,
you're down.
I always wants to see a guy with a kid with a cleric with a little collar and
everything. Oh No, you're not having fun. Right, right, right. Meanwhile,
where is the hijack terrifying people up in the cockpit?
He stayed in the cockpit but eventually at some point he hears this kind of
commotion from First-class and so he does open the door and he pokes his head
out and
everybody begins to applaud and applaud and we're done.
Totally sure about that last detail. It might be an embellishment,
but what seems clear is that around this time Allen Fund
is starting to feel kind of trap.
He'd been so successful at bugging the backstage at mussing up the line between
private and public and real life and Showbiz that he couldn't when he needed to,
he couldn't reassert that clear line.
I was worried that he was going to come up with some idea to try to mitigate the
situation and deal with it.
Actually what she says ended up happening was he got so frustrated that he
decided to just deal with the hijackers himself. Yes.
So he starts formulating a plan to grab the guy and knock him to the floor and
my mother saying, don't you do anything? You idiot.
I have two babies on this plane. Leave that alone. Sit down.
So he's going to be like Zorro. Yes.
Apparently the flight attendants had to tell them to sit down
like what happens now?
Will you have you took it to the point where now the plane is landing in what?
I guess the people in the plane think is Florida.
So you put on the front of the plane known as Cuba, Cuba. Correct.
When we taxied into the terminal,
greeted as the plane is opened by Cuban military officers,
I saw a Cuban soldier had a gun in his hand and he had bandoliers, you know,
with lots of bullets on it and they'd been circled, lear applying.
And it seems at this point everyone on the plane from maybe the first time with
like,
oh, everybody really got it. That it was a hijacking.
That was finally the reveal just really late.
And the story goes when they're getting off the plane.
When these Cuban soldiers are escorting them off the plane,
he was standing at his seat and through a twisty aspect of human psychology,
all the passengers were filing down the aisle past him.
They began to take their feelings out on him. Huh?
And they became angry at him and each one of them had sort of their own grab bag
of curses for him as if he had tricked them as if he had set them up in some
way. And the last person in that line turned to my father and said,
smile my ass.
That did happen.
Smile my ass was the closing remark on no business smile,
my ass [inaudible]
to me the meaning of this scene is that here's a man who he has helped create a
situation where people in some kind of peril don't know that they are in peril,
that they've been blinded by the device that he created.
It suggest that's the beginning of something blurry,
which didn't use to be as much.
It's funny like when I hear that plane scene it's like I'm almost nostalgic for
that kind of confusion cause what we have now is like actually way more
confusing and I think yeah,
because we all have these cameras so we're always taking these candid pictures
of ourselves.
But like obviously in theory they're candid but they're not really candid
because we've taken like four of them and the one we choose,
we put a filter on and I think it's interesting nowadays is what Jacob Smith
talks about as being interesting, which is that a desperate user,
Matt Kielty again, he was sort of off of mine because we were hashing this out.
Now what becomes fun to look at isn't looking for people and they're the faces
they make when they find out that they're on camera.
It's like poking and pulling apart.
People who know that know that they know that they're on camera.
Like what I do and I read people's Facebook pages and Twitter like Twitter is
like I'm,
I'm trying to figure out what they were thinking when they crafted that sentence
and how they were trying to represent themselves and present themselves to the
world. You're trying to figure out what part of that post is real. Yeah,
exactly. Cool. Yeah.
Well what he's really saying is that is that everyone who becomes an Allan Fund
and the and the people on the plane, like the confusion is very basic.
Like if you're going to go on Facebook,
then you are a little bit of an Allen Fund. If you're going to go on Twitter,
if you're going to do that, then you're producing these shows.
Then if you're actually trying to figure out how the other people are reacting
to you or how you read them or how they're reading you. Yeah.
Then you're a little bit like you're stuck on the plane cause you don't know
what's real and what's show. Yeah. In a way,
if you split Allan Front and half as opposed the showman and the audience.
Now everyone is in the showman and the audience. I could both part. Yeah.
It's like, I think we're Helen fonting ourselves.
[inaudible] star dude smile.
You're on candid camera.
Enormous thanks to our producer. Lots of Nasser also co-producer, Matt Kielty,
and a special thanks to the fund family.
They couldn't have been more accommodating and were generous. Also, Jim,
Zack and the Eastern Airlines employee association. Yeah.
I just want to close by wishing our producer Lynn Levy a heartfelt thanks and
good luck as she walks down the hall to work with our colleagues at studio three
60 we love you, Lynn.